hello reject nation i can only do that
because i only got two hours of sleep i
was
so excited what's your favorite scary
movie it is yeah it's easier to do when
you don't
so excited for the screen trailer man
scream is my favorite horror movie of
all time growing up this is true i
actually had a laserdisc copied it onto
a vhs i would watch it every sunday
after sunday mass yeah okay we'll get
pizza guy which is near where john lives
and then go home
watch
watch me some screams saw it countless
countless times and i was like six years
old and it's remained my favorite horror
movie since so you best bet i'm excited
for this man anytime you mention scream
and i i really think these directors are
up for the task to take over the helm of
the stream after the passing of what's
craving i think they did an amazing job
with ready or not yeah let's let's see
what's in store
[Music]
i don't think it's amber
this isn't funny amber would you like to
play a game
jigsaw
[Music]
[Music]
yeah he's back yeah he's back
[Music]
something about
she still looks great man yeah
which means that whoever this is gonna
keep coming for you
you ready
for this
oh dude a wheelchair to survive
jack quick attacks
[Music]
whatever his link is
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
damn look at all that man
yo
[Music]
was that the
is that the original house or am i just
tripping right now
yeah
them to go back there after all this
time is that the original it looked like
the original house isn't it the
staircase and everything yeah i don't
know i might just be tripping balls
it could be but i also just wouldn't put
it past it all right there's one way to
find out i was skimming this footage
online of this original screen movie we
went to the whole screen movie it could
be the i don't know
it's like the staircase and it's been
many years so it could just be updated
well it looks like it could be the same
house it looks like that kind of house
for sure and especially going back i bet
they want to evoke as much of the
original sets and whatnot as they can to
get you nostalgic
you know dewey and dewey especially
though seems like he's really grown up
as a as a character i mean you'd expect
him to and i don't remember scream for
as well as i otta here especially you
know he seems like he's not as like the
the affable goofy dewey that we remember
him to be and in fact i was like i took
him quite seriously what i'm getting at
he seems like a quite a badass
not as much of a wet blanket yeah
exactly and even uh sydney especially
too like by this point they've had to
encounter this so often they're just so
much more uh ready for the job whenever
this comes around but i'm loving the way
the direction of this is appearing at
least and like the way it's being
everything's being framed and the way
they're dealing with like cool camera
angles and whatnot i'm really looking
forward to it it feels like very classic
scream to me you know i guess what's
missing for me from this from this
particular trailer what are they doing
that's brand new with it because right
now it feels very familiar i have so
much faith that they can bring something
fresh to this because i really enjoyed
the last movie they did and this took a
long time to get off the ground yeah and
it even took nev campbell some
convincing from my understanding they
had to like they wrote her a letter and
there was a real talk that they wanted
to have with her it would scream was the
movie that influenced us the most into
getting into horror so we really have
some ideas for this and it was one of
those productions where they kept so
much of its secret to a lot of the cast
members for such a long time even while
filming not even the person who ends up
being the killer knew he was the killer
until they saw the movie hey that's the
perfect way to do it i don't know i
wouldn't put it with happy i'm the
killer well you know they love to throw
red herrings out for most every
character especially the further you get
into the screen franchise so in a way i
could maybe see that working out
although you know for your crucial
scenes i think it would be pretty hard
to keep that under wraps uh but yeah i
agree this has all the things i think
you would want it's yeah like the look
of more grizzle dewey maybe he's gonna
be a bit more of a seasoned cop at this
point because even in part four he was a
bit of a womp womp character nev
campbell coming back and filling i feel
like that's the new thing we're doing is
all the final girls are coming back is
just like hardened badasses yeah it's a
perfect take for this franchise i think
especially it suits it and yeah i'm just
waiting for what is going to set this
one apart in a meta context what's going
to suit it so well for our time and
place today and having finally seen
ready or not as well as being pretty
wowed by radio silences vhs vhs segment
and a couple other things they've done
like i am really confident that they can
deliver the punch and my favorite part
of this trailer was just their
cinematography and mood like it looks
really kind of menacing in a way that
befits scream but also looks like it's
augmented for the now it looks like a
bit more visceral and punchy just in
terms of how it's gonna portray its
visual style knowing their style i would
presume it's probably going to land that
way i think though what i really love
about this trailer in particular because
i remember the feelings i had when the
screen 4 trailer debuted and that was
you know obviously after scream three
which was like to me at least the
weakest of the original trilogy to get
this trailer it's just pure horror yeah
you know and it's not trying to do
the meta commentary
they're not going like double and down
look how smart we are reboot look at us
now
we're doing it they didn't focus on that
it wasn't the general vibe here and
trying to be winking at the audience
throughout they just made this feel more
like the first screen movie
especially and it's just advertising of
just a straightforward whodunit
capitalizing on the fear and the horror
and the tension while you got like a
little bit of humor there just with the
return of like you know gail and sydney
sharing the screen together again but
it's nice even seeing like how their
bond is really tightened up too whoa
whoa slowing this down they have this
shot here better not be killing my boy
dewey or knowing dewey probably just got
stabbed and injured he's still alive
what i love is that ghost face is back
so someone's obviously posing as ghost
face there's a new target they're all
returning just because
they have to they'll have to take this
guy this is their trauma this is what
they have to face yeah yeah and they're
it's not like i have a book coming out
or anything like that or maybe it is but
another book at least in this trailer
it's just they're doing this because
this is probably the thing that has
never ever left their mind and they got
to live with daily so i get the
impression that it'll also be character
driven simultaneously with it especially
on the dewey side like dewey was the one
who stood out the most to me because he
just looked like he's just down on his
luck and not having a good time looking
like a gay don't live in a trailer yeah
it's like i would you just think this
guy really if i finally retire with gail
but uh
doesn't look like it yeah yeah one it
looks like yeah you've got like a bunch
of your returning cast and the whole
bunch of of young people including like
dylan minette who's been in half the
recent horror movies so i feel like you
also have some that's where your maybe
metacasting will come in and then you'll
have the body count piling up on the the
younger characters and then all of our
legacy characters will find a way to
leak out of this one again and the
openings is this opening of the trailer
is presumably the opening scene which is
you know very traditional screen as well
yeah yeah but i like the uh the you know
updating with the whole like
smart house thing like that seemed like
at least a hint as to how this could be
unique to now all right guys well what
did you think about the screen trailer
leave your thoughts down below i for one
am very much looking forward to this i i
have have a lot of faith and and who's
involved and i know kevin williamson the
the original screenwriter is is
producing it but they got two new
screenwriters for this as well
uh scream writers okay
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below and hey we'll catch you guys soon
you